ist es außerirdisches leben das für den
mysteriösen methanausstoß auf dem mars
verantwortlich ist mit hilfe des nasa
rover curiosity wurden jetzt
spektakuläre neue erkenntnisse gewonnen
was also steckt hinter dem mysteriösen
maß methan krieg zum science im future
ein thema zu dem es immer wieder neue
erkenntnisse gibt über die wir hier
regelmäßig berichten also abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst man hat sich willkommen
feststeht bestimmte mikroben könnten in
mars ähnlichen würden nicht nur
überleben sondern sogar stoffwechsel
betreiben nicht wenige fachleute
weltweit gehen davon aus dass es sich um
außerirdisches leben handelt dass das
methan sporadisch auf dem roten planeten
produziert schon mehrmals hatte der nasa
rover curiosity proben von methangas auf
dem mars sammeln können ein hinweis auf
leben der trays gas orbiter kurz tgo der
esa dagegen konnte bisher keine methan
oben liefern
dabei wurde er doch extra dafür
abgestellt um in der marsatmosphäre gase
aufzuspüren die selbst in geringen
konzentrationen verfügbar sind ein
riesiges rätsel also dass
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
den letzten nerv raubt waren die
messungen von cork city möglicherweise
falsch hatte der rover möglicherweise
selbst das gas ausgestoßen oder liegt es
etwa an seinem standort fragen über
fragen
doch jetzt hat ein nasa forschungsteam
neue hinweise gesammelt demnach scheinen
die tageszeiten auf dem roten planeten
entscheidend zu sein für den ausstoß des
methans wie kann das sein und was
bedeuten diese erkenntnisse für unsere
suche nach außerirdischen leben die
antworten auf all diese fragen und noch
viel mehr gibt es jetzt in diesem video
nicht wenige fachleute sind sich ganz
sicher dass wir kurz vor der großen
entdeckung stehen und schon bald auf
außerirdisches leben stoßen werden erst
vor kurzem hatte der mars rover
curiosity eine spannende entdeckung in
dem jahrmilliarden alten gestein des
mars gemacht organischer materie nämlich
also sehr einfache
kohlenstoffverbindungen die hinweise auf
eine
die zeit auf dem roten planeten geben
konkret handelt es sich bei der
entdeckung um aromatische khalifa tische
und theo chemische verbindung
möglicherweise hat es dort also nur mal
so von mikroben gewimmelt ein
forschungsteam aus bologna hat er
außerdem gleich einen ganzen see aus
flüssigem wasser entdeckt und war rund
anderthalb kilometer unter dem eis des
südpols die radardaten vom mars express
der europäischen raumfahrt agentur esa
zeigen dies und zwar in der südpolregion
des roten planeten im plan um ausstrahle
die daten zeigen in dieser abgegrenzten
region dieselben signaturen wie sehen
unter dem eis in polar regionen der erde
und in unterirdischen seen wie
beispielsweise dem lake willens in der
antarktis wimmelt es nur so von mikroben
bedeutet dass etwa das leben auch in
diesem gletschersee des mars existiert
flüssiges wasser ist schließlich nach
forschenden meinungen die
grundvoraussetzung für leben wie wir es
kennen
dazu kommt das langjährige und bislang
ungelöste rätsel des methans in der mars
luft auf der erde entsteht methan durch
biologische prozesse beispielsweise wenn
rinder ihre nahrung verdauen messung auf
dem mars hatten außerdem gezeigt dass
die konzentration des methans das jahr
über stark schwankt ist das etwa ein
beweis für biologische aktivitäten
ausgeschlossen ist es allerdings nicht
dass das methan durch geologische
prozesse freigesetzt wird denn das gas
kann auch geochemische entstehen zum
beispiel durch die uv bestrahlung von
gesteinsmaterial die große frage
zu diesem mysteriösen rätsel lautet also
wer oder was produziert sporadisch
dieses methan zum größten teil besteht
die atmosphäre des roten planeten aus
kohlendioxid zu kleineren anteilen sind
auch sauerstoff aragon kohlenmonoxid und
stickstoff zu finden und die dichte
dieser gase schwankt innerhalb eines
jahres schon seit längerer zeit ist
fachleuten die tatsachen bekannt dass
der gasdruck im winter und damit auch
die dichte der spurengase sinkt
begründet liegt das an dem co2 das als
trocken eis an den polen des mars
auskristallisiert so verschwindet es im
winter aus der atmosphäre im sommer dann
nimmt die gasdichte wieder zu in den
letzten jahren gab es ein erstes
spannendes rätsel denn daten liegt
dass vor allem die konzentration von
methan sehr stark und abwechselnd
normalerweise liegt sie bei ja das
blenden vereinen also 00 00 00 04 schock
ich habe die richtige zahl genannt
prozent ist also quasi kaum messbar
doch im sommer steigt der wert um 60
prozent an nach ansicht der fachleute
kann dies keineswegs mit der saisonalen
schwankungen erklärt werden und so ist
dieses rätseln bis heute ungelöst in den
jahren 2013 und 2019 hatte curiosity
außerdem besonders überraschende
messwerte geliefert und die hatten für
weiter verwirrung gesorgt es war
überraschend erhöhte methan werte und
das nicht zu knapp dass leser
spektrometer hatte vor zwei jahren einen
wert von trendone parts per billion 21
jahr teile pro milliarde teilen
ermittelt eine konzentration die 20 mal
höher ist als der normalerweise im geld
krater vorherrschende hintergrund wäre
doch so plötzlich wie das methan
aufgetaucht war
so plötzlich war es auch wieder
verschwunden die nasa
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
hatten geheuer sind die damals einige
tage später ein folge experiment
durchführen lassen und dem methan peek
war verschwunden
diese messung ergab dann dass der methan
wert wieder auf weniger als 1 ppb
abgesunken war also ppb parts
verbilligen quasi der hintergrund wert
des gale kraters irgendwo muss also eine
vorübergehende ausgasung stattgefunden
haben so die vermutung der fachleute
doch wo genau und was oder wer genau
steckt dahinter auf all das kann
curiosity leider keine antworten geben
ein weiteres rätsel das die
wissenschafts community um den schlaf
bringt hat mit dem exomars trace gas
orbiter kunst der europäischen
weltraumagentur esa zu tun bereits seit
fünf jahren also seit 2000 16 befindet
sich der orbiter in der umlaufbahn des
roten planeten
es handelt sich im wahrsten sinne des
wortes um einen kniffler tgo hat das
große ziel die atmosphäre des mars
genauer zu untersuchen haben gase wie
methan und andere spurengase die sich
dort befinden biologische oder
geologische ursachen und obwohl der
orbiter genau dafür ausgelegt ist ist es
ihm bislang nicht gelungen methan proben
zu liefern
doch wie kann das sein dazu sagt der
nasa wissenschaftler chris web statt
als der tgo 2016 mit an den start kam
hatte ich zu 100 erwartet dass das
op-team berichten wird dass es überall
auf dem mars eine kleine menge methan
gibt ich war total überrascht dass das
europäische team kein methan finden
konnte und so machten sich die fachleute
auf die suche nach einer erklärung sie
überprüften ob der kohlgasse timo war
möglicherweise selbst methan aus stift
zudem analysierten sie auch ganz genau
ob seine messergebnisse etwas mit seiner
position seinem untergrund oder dem
abrieb der reifen zu tun haben könnte
dazu chris website ich kann gar nicht
genug betonen welchen aufwand wir
betrieben haben um sicherzustellen dass
die messung korrekt sind
denn fest steht sowohl cargo city als
auch dem leser orbiter ist eigentlich
voll und ganz zu vertrauen der tgo gilt
als goldstandard er ist darauf
spezialisiert methan und andere gase zu
messen aber auch das sogenannte tuner
blazer spektrometer tls instrument an
bord des curiosity rovers gilt als
absolut zuverlässig es wird sogar als
brandfrüherkennung auf der
internationalen raumstation iss genutzt
zugelassen ist es außerdem für den
einsatz in kampfflugzeugen oder in öl
pipelines hier hilft es der besatzung
den sauerstoff und kohlendioxid gehalt
in ihrem gesichtsmasken zu überwachen
umso größer also die verwunderung dass
entweder der orbiter oder aber der rover
falsche ergebnisse liefern könnte
der kanadische planeten wissenschaftler
john moore hatte bereits vor einiger
zeit die vermutung in den raum gestellt
dass beide recht haben könnten sowohl
der kolosse tiroler als auch der trays
gas orbiter sollte er damit recht
behalten auch er ist am kolosse die
projektbeteiligten und hat vor allem die
wind muster im geld krater im visier
er vermutet dass die tageszeit der
methan messung eine entscheidende rolle
spielt das instrument von cargo city
arbeitet meistens nachts dann wenn keine
anderen instrumente des rovers aktiv
sind der esa orbiter dagegen arbeitet am
tat und nutzt dabei das sonnenlicht
dieser hypothese gegen das nasa
forschungsteam dann direkt auf den grund
und ließ curiosity tagsüber
momentan suchen eine echte premiere das
ziel-s instrument hatte zuvor noch nie
am tag gemessen und auch hier konnte
kein methan aufgespürt werden
es ist also der zeitpunkt und nicht der
ort der methan auftauchen lässt oder
eben nicht daraus schließen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
dass die tageszeit und möglicherweise
auch die temperatur
einen einfluss darauf hat wann methan
auf dem mars aufgespürt werden kann
möglicherweise ist es für colo city
nachts auf spürbar dass aus dem boden
das geld kraters entweicht so befindet
es sich also während der messung von
carlos city in der nacht an der mars
oberfläche und zwar in konzentrierter
form dann steigt es den tag über in die
atmosphäre ist dort dann aber nicht mehr
in mengen vorhanden die messbar sind für
den giro ist es damit unauffindbar somit
scheint sichtlichen prothese des
kanadischen wissenschaftlers john moore
zu bestätigen dazu nasa forscher paul
murphy john sagte voraus dass methan im
laufe des tages effektiv auf null sinken
sollte unsere beiden tages messungen
haben dies bestätigt das ist also eine
möglichkeit die unterschiedlichen
messergebnisse zu erklären mit diesen
erkenntnissen tut sich ein neues rätsel
um den roten planeten auf denn methan
ist eigentlich als sehr stabiles molekül
bekannt dass sich deswegen eigentlich in
der atmosphäre sammeln sollte fachleute
gehen davon aus dass sie sich erst nach
etwa 300 jahren zersetzt durch
sonnenstrahlung demnach müsste es aber
eigentlich auch vom esa besser
aufgespürt werden können
verläuft dieser zersetzungsprozess also
auf dem mars schneller und falls methan
nicht nur aus dem boden des geldgebers
entweicht sondern auch an anderen
stellen müssten sich das gas dann trotz
der atmosphärischen vermischung nicht
dennoch auch für den leser peter tgo
auffindbar sein werden wir also schon
bald spuren von leben auf dem mars
stoßen eine andere frage hat die
forschung so in ihren bann gezogen und
es gibt noch andere ansätze eislage auf
dem mars werden wir hier auf leben
stoßen anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren diesen kanal dafür gibt's
unter jedem video den abo button also
worauf warten jetzt klicken und nichts
mehr verpassen
bis dann
bleibt dran